in our ongoing series school matters
we're looking at the debates over
how and when to reopen schools safely
but some things are not a matter of
debate they are settled fact and that is
this it's a challenging time for
teachers that goes
for teachers returning to the classroom
but also those teachers who are
continuing to work
online so what we're going to do this
morning is we want to say thank you to
just a few of the teachers
who've had such a big impact on people's
lives students all over the country what
we did is we asked four successful
americans
i think you've heard of them bill gates
chelsea clinton musician josh groban
and actor levar burton we wanted them to
tell us about the teachers
who've inspired them hi i'm bill gates
i'm josh groban i am chelsea clinton i'm
levar burton
fawn is here here back to school
one of my most influential teachers has
got to be mrs twigg
third grade hannah american elementary
in hanow germany
on certain rainy afternoons mrs twigg
would put me in front of the class
and have me read while she went to the
teacher's lounge to make herself
a cup of tea i was the best reader in
my third grade class and it was the
first time
in my life that somebody outside of my
family recognized that
i was good at cycling i had a talent
gift
it's one of my favorite fables the
tortoise and the hair
great teachers help students get excited
about
learning mrs blanche caffierre
a teacher at view ridge elementary
school in seattle was that kind of
teacher for me
i was a very shy 4th grader with a messy
desk and terrible handwriting
i tried to hide the fact that i loved to
read because i was worried it would look
strange to my classmates mrs cappier
pulled me out of my shell by sharing her
love of books
she pushed me to read challenging ones
and then asked me interesting questions
that made me think
about what i'd read she listened to what
i had to say
looking back on it now there's no
question that she helped spark my love
for learning and helped inspire
the gates foundation's work to help
every child in america
get the benefit of great teachers
i want to give a huge thanks to the late
great norman cohen my theater teacher at
the los angeles county high school for
the arts for giving me my first lead
role in a play
and my musical theater teacher there
gary sorensen who gave me my first
lead role in a musical if i were a rich
man
[Music]
having the arts in my life as a student
just changed my life
as a shy introverted kid who had a
really hard time expressing myself
having the arts as a tool to do that not
only opened up a world of possibility
for me but i know it does it for
millions of kids
around the world
i'm so profoundly grateful to dr sadie
mitchell who was my first grade teacher
at forest park elementary school in
little rock arkansas
dr mitchell set the bar for what an
extraordinary
teacher should be and she did it every
day
she did it in helping us work on our
penmanship
she did it in helping us learn to count
and she did it whenever we had a bad day
by reminding us that tomorrow was a new
day
i just hope that i'm able to have even a
little bit of the same effect on some of
my students today
and i hope that every student is as
lucky as i was to have a dr mitchell
in their lives thank you to the great
teachers and the arts teachers out there
who are bringing a spark of humanity
into our classrooms
when we need it in this world more than
ever i can't tell you how important it
is to have somebody
recognize our potential to see it and
nurture it thank you this is
so as teachers get ready to welcome
students back to their classroom
either in person or virtually i want to
say thank you for your dedication
you're changing lives and doing amazing
work
and guys i know we're going to have a
lot to say about that segment but before
we do i just want to have a little
reminder here uh for people out there
watching if you have a teacher who came
to mind as you were watching that a
teacher who inspired you
we want to hear from you find us on
social media share your story and we
might
even feature it on a future segment
because teacher appreciation does not
end with this segment right here it goes
on and on galen anthony yeah it sure
does
and one great teacher literally can
change your life
you really can you see that right there